good morning welcome to day two of the
2020
brain initiative investigators virtual
meeting
um i hope that you've enjoyed the
platform
that we've been able to put the meeting
on i think it's worked very well from my
experience yesterday and
this has been a great opportunity to
bring everybody together
so i am dr deborah toosey i'm director
of the national institute on deafness
and other communication disorders
and it is my real pleasure to moderate
the session today with dr edward chang
this is a plenary keynote address
by dr chang he is the bulls biomedical
investigator and professor of
neurological surgery at the university
of california in san francisco
dr chang's clinical expertise is
surgical therapies for epilepsy
pain and brain tumors he specializes in
advanced
neurophysiologic brain mapping methods
including awake speech and motor mapping
to safely perform neurosurgical
procedures in
eloquent areas of the brain his research
focuses on the discovery of cortical
mechanisms of high order
neurologic function in humans dr chang's
laboratory has demonstrated the detailed
functional organization
of the human speech cortex his clinical
research focuses on
outcomes related to epilepsy surgery and
neuromodulation
dr chang is co-director of the center
for neural engineering and prostheses at
uc berkeley
and uc san francisco he's principal
investigator of the darpa sudnet subnets
project to develop
advanced therapies for neuropsychiatric
conditions
dr chang is the 2015 blavatnik
national laureate in life sciences a
recipient of the nih director's new
innovator award
and a howard hughes medical investigator
faculty scholar
he will be speaking on the functional
architecture of speech
motor cortex and i'll remind you that
the
question section will be open and you
can post questions during the session
and we'll have a q a afterwards
dr chang
thank you for the kind introduction it
is a pleasure to be here today with all
of you with the sixth annual brain
initiative investigators meeting
my name is eddie chang i'm a professor
of neurosurgery at the university of
california in san francisco
titled my talk is the functional
architecture of the speech motor cortex
for this next half hour i'm going to be
talking about our brain initiative award
that focuses on how we speak
specifically how the brain controls our
ability to control
the vocal tract when we give rise to
fluent speech
when we begin our work much of what we
knew about the speech motor cortex was
inferred from the
somatotopic organization that was
described at the turn of the century
this is one of my favorite illustrations
hand drawn
by the founder of modern neurosurgery
harvey cushing in 1906.
i'm showing the enlarged view of the
motor cortex organization that was
labeled by
dr cushing this was a precursor to
wilder penfield's more famous
description of what is now known as the
little man
the homunculus here the lateral
two-thirds of the motor cortex is
dedicated to
movement representations of the face the
lips
the jaw pallet and the most important
thing i want to point out is the vocal
cords
which are labeled at the bottom of the
motor strip
near the temporal lobe they're
identified by the labeling that says
vocal cords
speaking is a hallmark of our species
it is the most complex motor action that
we do
it requires the coordination of over 100
muscles
each of which has tremendous degrees of
freedom
and we do it rapidly to express on
average 120 words per minute when we
speak
the miracle is that despite this
complexity
we all learn to speak effortlessly
this talk will focus on new principles
of how the human cortex controls the
vocal tract
to produce fluent speech
speech is created by two principal
actions that shape the breath
one is the source of our vocalizations
known as
the voice is created by the vibrations
of vocal folds
as air is pushed through and the pitch
of our voice which is also
created by the vibration of those vocal
folds as well
number two is what is known as the
filters
those refer to the shapes of the upper
vocal tract that create specific
resonances for every consonant and vowel
i'm a neurosurgeon at ucsf and i take
care of patients with epilepsy and brain
tumors
in this context our patients are
implanted with intracranial electrodes
for one to two weeks
for the purpose of localizing seizures
and brain mapping in preparation for
removing a epilepsy focus
each one millimeter electrode here
records activity of thousands of neurons
for now these kind of recordings
are the only tool that we have to study
with the human brain
with simultaneous spatial and temporal
resolution
at the scales of millimeters in
milliseconds
this opportunity to work with fellow
human
patients and volunteers is critical to
our understanding of the physiology of
speech
this video will briefly show an example
of the space
and time activity of neural activity at
each one of these electrode sites
ship building is a most fascinating
process
what you just heard is a simple sentence
with about half a dozen words that was
articulated by one of our
volunteer subjects each of those
electrodes corresponds to
recordings of thousands of neurons
uh each of which are sampled as a group
at each one of those electrodes
and what you just saw was what we call
the spatial temporal code
of neural activity that is the neural
code
that gives rise to the ability to speak
i'm going to focus on two particular
papers in this
presentation one has to do with
our brain initiative project to
understand how we control our local
pitch
in the human laryngeal motor cortex when
we speak
and this was a project that was
spearheaded by a graduate student in my
lab
named benjamin dictor
not much is really known about how the
brain
controls the larynx and the larynx has
two really important functions like i
alluded to earlier
is the source of our vocalizations
from the vibrations of the vocal folds
that we call
voicing and it has a separate function
that
changes the pitch of our voice which we
use in english
or intonation
ben's project focuses on trying to
understand how the brain
controls these two different functions
when we speak
then created a task where our human
volunteer subjects were asked to
read a single sentence where the
emphasis on one particular word
changed on this on a given trial
so here he was trying to understand how
pitch control
can be used to determine uh how the
larynx is encoded
in the motor cortex from reddit
he found a sentence i never said she
stole my money
i had the volunteers emphasized one
particular word
on a given trial i never said she stole
my money
it's very different than i never said
she stole my money
those have different emphasis and have
different implied meaning
that's how we use pitch to convey a
different kind of
intonation in english
what ben found was that there was a
fairly well circumscribed
area in the top part of the motor cortex
as well as an area down below that
corresponded
to laryngeal cortex movements
what you see on the right side are the
pitch contours
for each given trial where a particular
word was emphasized
for example that first set of blue lines
corresponds to
the single trials where the word i was
emphasized
and the data that you see underneath
that corresponds to the single trial
neural activity
on each one of those trials
when you look across the different words
in that one sentence when it's time
aligned to the emphasized word or the
stressed
word you can see that the neural
activity
tightly corresponds and is aligned with
the stressed word so what you can see
here is that this one particular
electrode
in this area that we call the dorsal
larynx cortex
doesn't care particularly about the word
itself or the word identity but is
definitely interested in tracking or
controlling
the increase in the pitch at those
particular works
it doesn't code the information about
the words themselves but rather the
pitch
that is correlated with those
independent visual words in this
particular task
he also found that when participants
sang melodies such as del rey me
that these particular electrodes in the
dorsal original cortex
were activated very selectively and
on top of that this part of the brain
actually
responds to when he played back
these vocalizations in these sentences
that in fact these areas
not only are involved in producing
um the pitch changes when one speaks but
they are also involved
in the perception basically when someone
is listening
this part of brain also is tracking the
pitch information
what ben found was that this dorsal
laryngial cortex
was fairly well localized especially in
the right hemisphere
to an area that was directly lateral and
inferior
to the hand of representation in the
motor cortex
here it's circled by a dotted line on
the right hemisphere
and as well though more variable on the
left hemisphere
note this is different than what was
described at the turn of the century
when
most of what had been known there was
actually studied in
not in humans but in non-human primates
where a more ventral located dorsal
laryngo cortex was found near the
temporal lobe
not in this dorsal area near the hand
representation
because we found that there were
auditory representations
in the speech motor cortex
and the dorsal laryngeal cortex a basic
question was
how do we know that the neural activity
there corresponds to
the control and control of the larynx
muscles as opposed to just the auditory
perception of the sound
ben did several studies to show that the
timing of the activity actually
proceeded when people spoke
when they were in the speaking condition
but when
he looked at when they were listening
the neural activity was primarily
after they heard these changes in the
pitch so that was our first
clue that the neural activity that we're
seeing in the dorsal laryngeal cortex
is motor in nature but um
to take this further and to make it more
definitive and to show that it is
causally involved in the
control of the larynx we did an
electrical stimulation
experiment where we stimulated the
dorsal laryngeal
cortex and found that it evokes
laryngeal movement as detected with emg
in a subset of the volunteers in the
subject
volunteer subjects in the study
for undergoing brain mapping as part of
their brain surgery we had a
non-invasive way of measuring the emg
the muscle movements in the local folds
as part of their brain mapping before
the surgery
the surgical resection and what we found
was that when we stimulated this dorsal
laryngeal cortex
most of the responses in fact were able
to evoke
movements in the vocal folds in this
dorsal financial motor cortex and
what we found was that when you increase
the size of the electrical stimulation
you would actually have an increase in
the size
of the evoked response
this just shows you a plot of some of
the evoked potentials
with the current voltage
and the quantitative quantitative
relationship
between the stimulation magnitude and
the amplitude of the emg
response
in a subset of other volunteers we
stimulated this area when they were
undergoing awake surgery
we found that it could also have a
different effect
um not just causing the vocal folds to
move
but in fact invoking vocalization
and this has a spectrogram of the kind
of sounds that are created when you
stimulate
the area in or around the dorsal orange
motor cortex
it produces a sound like this
it's a vocalization that is
involuntarily created
the second paper that i'd like to
highlight in this basic
description of speech motor cortex was
a project that was spearheaded by
graduate student
josh chartier and postdoctoral fellow
gopala anumachita pali
the title of the paper is encoding of
articulatory kinematic trajectories in
the human speech
sensory motor cortex and
while our first study was focused on how
do we
create the voicing signal and pitch
changes from the larynx
what we call the source of the signal
this paper focuses on more on the filter
which i alluded to earlier which is
essentially the shaping
of the vocal tract and the movements and
the jaws the lips the tongue
to shape the breath in two words
and there are two key challenges for
studying these kind of movements
one is that these are very in natural
speech very continuous
and uh complex um
and that hasn't really been done before
number two is how do we how does one
study the movements
of the vocal tract this is complex
because the movements
of the vocal tract are a lot more
complicated than the ones of
let's say our arms and legs which are
skeletal joint based
muscles
so this brief video shows you some of
the movements that we are trying to
characterize
when someone is speaking the lips the
jaw the tongue
they're coordinated in a highly precise
way and again these are not
simple skeletal joint based movements
but ones that
operate as sphincters as hydrostats as
totally different set of dynamics for
movement
and this is what we all do when we speak
fluently
we've approached this question in two
different ways one
is by doing simultaneous recordings
from the brain while non-invasively
measuring the kinematics the movements
of these different parts
of the vocal tract using video camera
and
ultrasound that's placed under the jaw
to track movements
and um with just a very simple
application of things like
colored lipstick in paints
we can use computer vision to track
essentially the movements while someone
is uttering a sentence or series of
words
in this particular study we focused on a
method that is called
electromagnetic mid sagittal
articulography
emma in short and
what we did was we used the data that
was collected from
a different group of volunteers who had
pellets that were
placed on these different parts of the
vocal tract as they spoke a series of
natural
sentences these pellets were placed on
very specific locations like the upper
and lower lip
the lower teeth the
tongue blade and tongue tip and
in the back of the town
gopala one of the first authors on this
paper
developed a artificial intelligence
algorithm
the machine learning algorithm
essentially to
take and understand the mapping between
the acoustic spectrogram and the
movements that were being recorded
by the ms system so as these
volunteers were speaking we recorded
through a microphone
uh the acoustic properties of what
they uh said the cat's meow always hurts
my ears so you can basically
correlate the movements with different
sound features in the spectrogram
and once he had developed this tool
what he was able to do was to
create an inversion method that is
called uh
acoustic to articulatory inversion using
a kind of uh machine learning called the
deep neural network
and what this allowed us to do was to
take the sound
essentially the recordings of people's
voices and their sentences
and to project and infer what were the
movements that were taking place in the
vocal tract
this inversion method turned out to be
quite powerful in reconstructing
accurately the movements of different
parts of the vocal tract over time
so at the very top you see the
spectrogram for a given sentence from
the acoustics
and underneath it you see the different
plots of
articulator positions from that emma
the real data is shown
by the different colors and the
data that is inferred by this inversion
algorithm
is shown by in block and you can see
that it's high accuracy
as a method so this gave us a method to
take any
sentence that someone uttered and infer
what were the movements in the vocal
tract from
that speech
which meant that we didn't need to put
the pellets in the people
that were reporting the activity from
the brain which
was not tractable in our hospital
setting but did allow us
to infer the vocal tract movements
in this paper we describe how movements
of the vocal tract are encoded
by neural activity at single electrodes
on the upper left shows a red dot
corresponding to a single electrode in
the ventral sensory motor cortex
that's one electrode that we're going to
describe here as an example
the upper right shows the different
articulator movements at the positions
like the upper lip the lower lip
the lower incisor the tongue tip the
tongue blade the time dorsum
as a function of time and what we
basically did in this study
was to derive and compute a filter
which you see in plot b that
can describe and predict the neural
activity that we see at that one
electrode this is what we call an
encoding model
the derivation of this filter
or encoding model tells us
what properties or what kind of specific
movements are encoded by neural activity
of that one
particular electrode so if you focus on
b
it shows you the weighting of different
articulatory
positions and movements as a function of
time
for that one particular electrode and we
are looking for
that one set of filter weights that if
you convolve
with the movements themselves gives you
a prediction
of the neural activity that we recorded
each of those
electrodes
this is a way of estimating the tuning
property or
the kind of movements that that one
particular electrode
is controlling now instead of
showing this as filter weights we
decided to make it more visually
intuitive
by plotting the trajectory that
is described at each of these electrodes
on a sagittal a midline sagittal cross
section
of the vocal tract that essentially
tells you the kind of movements
at each one of these given points as a
function of time
so time in this plot is represented by
line thickness
the line gets thicker at each one of
these positions as a function of time
so in this particular schematic
what you're basically seeing is that
for this one electrode in the sensory
motor cortex it's associated
with movements where the tongue back and
what we call the tongue back and the
tongue dorsum
uh are depressed
and then come back up uh the tongue tip
moves forward towards the upper teeth
and then back down the lower incisor
goes up and then back down
what you will notice here is the
trajectories
of each one of these areas
has a very characteristic out and back
profile
they're not going in a circle they're
not going in random directions
but they in fact have stereotyped
out and back trajectory profiles and the
second thing
that you will notice is that it is not a
single
part of the vocal tract that is moving
but in fact it's a coordinated movement
it's not a single articulator but in
fact a coordinated movement
of the mouth and the tongue that is
being coded
by this one electrode and this is
some evidence to suggest that what we
call
speech primitives these are low
dimensional coordinated movements
being encoded by neurons in the speech
motor cortex to give you an example
of different kind of um and
the the wide variability in
heterogeneity
the different kind of uh encoding that
we see
at different electrodes i'll show you a
couple of examples
so for example when we say the word dad
the duh sound in dad is what we call a
coronal
trajectory where the tongue tip actually
goes to
the back of the upper tooth and um
that one particular electrode on the
brain is shown in red
this video basically shows the kind of
movements at each one of those pellet
positions
when the duh sound is made
you can see that the tongue tip goes up
to the teeth
and the tongue back goes down the lower
incisor goes up and down
that coordinated movement is encoded by
that one electrode
in red contrast that with
a different word pop the puff and
pop sound is what we call a labial
trajectory and the primary movements
there
are the transient closure of the lips
uh when we make that bilabial
uh sound that pus different electrode
shown in red
i'll show you the trajectory in this
very brief video here
you can see that the lips have the
largest
displacement and velocity coming up in
together
whereas the tongue is not moving in a
meaningful way
encoded by this one particular electron
so there's an example of an electrode
that
cares a lot about what's called labial
trajectory
which are important for sounds like
uh here's a different example for the
word kite
the cup and kite is one blue six volt we
call it a dorsal trajectory and the
primary movement here
uh this one electrode which is very
inferior near the temporal lobe
at the bottom of the sensory motor
cortex primarily encodes
back tongue movements where the back of
the tongue moves the top
of the velum you can see that here in
this
brief video showing the back tongue
moving up upwards
so here are three examples of different
kind of movements that are encoded by
neurons in the sensory motor cortex
for speaking
now
we weren't interested in just looking at
a couple of electrodes but in fact the
hundreds that we've collected over time
and this is just a subset that josh and
gopala described in their
2018 paper where each
column here corresponds to different
electrodes and each row
on the upper part corresponds to
different parts of the vocal tract
and there are different weightings
according to that encoding model
and then below that also shows
all of the different english phonemes
the different speech sounds in english
that um are arranged uh essentially by
different consonants and vowels etc
and the main point to take away from
this figure
is that in looking at these hundreds of
electrodes we can account
for the articulatory encoding for all
english
speech sounds for all english consonants
and vowels
how they are encoded by different
trajectories that are encoded by neural
activity
in this speech motor cortex
it's not just a small series of
different speed sounds but in fact by
looking at natural speech
over multiple trials we can now
describe the kinematic trajectories for
all english speech sounds encoded by the
neural activity in this
particular brain area
if you sort the
different trajectories and look at how
they
cluster using an algorithm called
hierarchical clustering we found
that while there's a lot of
heterogeneity of different
trajectory encodings they're in fact
four dominant patterns
and they correspond to some of the ones
that i've described earlier in the video
that are described by
movements that's the tone tip the tongue
back what we call dorsal
articulatory kinematic trajectory labial
and also vocalic ones that are related
to laryngeal movement
um the two papers that i've described
summarize our thinking and current state
of knowledge
about movement encoding in the larynx
and also the upper part of the vocal
tract that lifts the jaw
and the tongue and the last project that
i will describe
is what we call a decoding or bring
machine interface type of experiment
where
we wanted to address a very simple
question
that if we knew essentially what each of
these different spots
was doing in the speech motor cortex
could we
design an algorithm to decode
what words were spoken by someone by
just
looking at the neural activity alone
could we
reconstruct someone's voice and
sentences
and words based on the neural activity
alone one of our long-term goals
is to develop a way to restore
communication for people who have lost
the ability to speak
because of conditions like als or
brain stem stroke
a recent review that we described
in a recent review uh we described
uh a communication uh the communication
rates
across a variety of different modalities
and the typical kind of what we call
augmentative and assistive communication
devices typically get to around
10 to 15 words per minute
but natural speech hangs in the range of
120 to 150 words
per minute so the amount of information
that we convey when we speak
is far higher than what is currently
available
by assistive devices for people who have
communication disorder
this shows the basic algorithm in
the paper that was described that was uh
done by uh gopala and josh uh recently
where
again the goal here was to reconstruct
or to
synthesize words and sentences
from neural activity alone there
are a variety of different ways that one
can do this using
the kind of machine learning and deep
neural networks that are available today
the one particular strategy that we
focused on
was a two-step model where the in the
first step
the neural activity was converted into
articulatory movements
a computer simulation of articulatory
movements
similar to the ones that i've described
earlier in this talk
the second part of the decoder took
those decoded movements
and synthesized it into audible
speech waveforms so the two components
are
translating the neural activity into
articulatory kinematic movements
and then translating those movements
into audible waveforms
and this is what some of the data looks
like in this project
this is these are two different
sentences
the upper spectrogram corresponds to the
original
speech that was spoken by one of our
volunteer subjects
the bottom spectrogram corresponds to
what
was decoded using this two-step decoder
and you can see that it's far from
perfect it definitely misses a lot of
the key
detailed patterns but in fact does
capture a lot of the important
temporal aspects and different frequency
energy ranges
of the spectrogram that are relevant
so the upper spec is the original
spectrogram and the lower
is the spectrogram that is created from
brain activity alone
in this first part of the decoder uh
right our goal was essentially to take
what is called a biomimetic approach
model what happens in the vocal tract
itself and try to predict that neural
uh from the brain activity alone
to create a simulation of what's going
on in our vocal tract
when we speak
in this uh short video we'll just
describe essentially
you will hear for the first time what
these synthesized speech samples
actually sound like like i said this is
really our first attempt at trying to
synthesize speech from brain activity
alone
there's a lot of work to improve this
but nonetheless
is what's a very great place to start
what you'll first see is the neural
activity
from the electrodes that we're recording
from on the brain
you will then see the first part of the
decoder that
shows you the predicted articulatory
movements in the vocal tract
then you will hear the sentence that is
synthesized
then after that you can compare that
with the original audio that was
recorded from
the subjects
the prince that you are receiving is
signed available in move
the proof that you are seeking is not
available in books
the prince that you are seeking is
signed relevant in groups
she filled revision must not say any
process
shift building is a most fascinating
process
so we visited us nasty unique process
so i wanted to um
and there in terms of some of the work
that has come
out of our brain initiative project i
just want to
conclude with a couple of the principles
that we have learned about how the
speech motor cortex
works there's clear evidence now that
speech movements are encoded
in the motor cortex what we call the
oral facial or speech motor cortex which
occupies
at least two thirds of the motor cortex
which is very understudied
while the potential degrees of freedom
of those movements are very large and
complex
in fact the movements that are encoded
by the brain are limited
to a small set of coordinated kinematics
these gestures combined to give rise
to every speech sound in every language
and it's these units that allow us
to have essentially a universal code to
communicate and control
the different parts of the vocal tract
to produce speech sounds
in this series of papers we were able to
describe
that there are in fact two laryngeal
areas one is a dorsal laryngeal motor
cortex
as well as a ventral one that was
discovered a century earlier
but in fact two areas that do encode
information about
the larynx
that the local populations
in this speech motor cortex encode
articulatory
uh trajectories and uh low dimensional
set of movements that we call speech
primitives
and the final thing that i showed was
that it is in fact possible to decode
that neural activity that ensemble
of population neural activity for
potential
uh neuroprosthetic application for
people who are paralyzed
so i want to conclude by thanking
some really wonderful collaborators
and people who i've been able to work
with on these projects as part of this
nih brain initiative yield one
it's been an amazing experience and look
forward to talking to you soon
about any questions or comments you have
about the findings
thank you very much
all right thank you dr chang for that
very
informative and thought-provoking talk
i'll remind the audience to please
submit questions
we've had a few and while we're waiting
for
uh questions to get up i wanted to
to go ahead and ask the first question
so dr chang i know that you thought a
lot about the
ethical implications of your work
particularly in the development of a
speech neuroprosthesis
and i just wanted to pose sort of a
short series of questions related to
that
beginning with what patient population
do you think would be the first
population uh
to utilize this the speech narrow
prosthesis
in a group of patients who have
difficulty with speech production
and at what point during the disease
progression
do you think that you would begin
to introduce this work and then
uh finally given the invasive nature
of the electrode placement as you've
described it based on your work in the
epilepsy patients
you see a path forward for use of less
invasive
technology such as scalp recordings uh
to generate these cortical
representations
good morning i think those are wonderful
questions
and um they're such an important
starting place for
thinking about the future of this work
so we're really excited
about the prospect of a clinically
viable speech prosthetic
we certainly are not the first ones to
really envision that or dream of that
but
um and there's been a need for quite
some time
the main populations that we've been
thinking about are
folks who are suffering from a condition
called locked in syndrome where
you have full cognition but have no
voluntary movements
and there's a huge unmet need as
something i alluded to uh in the slides
is that
the amount of information that we can
convey with a lot of
existing current technology the
assistive and augmentative
communication we call aac are
really really important but not fast
enough
to restore what we like for normal
communications one that will look like
10 to 15 words per minute
whereas right now we're sitting in on
the order of like 100 150 words per
minute and
that's what um people are interested in
in doing to enhance so in thinking about
who would be the primary benefits
beneficiaries from a speech prosthetic
technology
um you know it probably makes the most
sense to to think about the people who
have the biggest unmet need right now
those who have the biggest communication
those are people who are suffering from
neurodegenerative conditions like als
where this can take place over the
course of weeks
months or years as a degenerative
process
or even in some acute cases where people
have suffered
a brain stem stroke and aren't unable to
speak
after that kind of disconnection from
the cerebrum to
the vocal structures i think that's a
really
clear and important starting point but
if we can validate in those populations
technology works and is robust and is
reliable
then there's a much broader population i
think of people who study you know who
suffer from kinds of dysarthria
um where there are injuries or cancer
relating to larynx the throat
um the mouth etc they could potentially
benefit from these kind of technologies
as well so starting with really the most
severe cases and then thinking through
um
where you know there's speech
abnormalities that we call
dysarthria which uh is a is a term
that refers to the inability to speak
fluently
and clearly um and there are a lot more
people that
suffer that kind of condition the second
question you asked was
about the future of of how this is done
and
um i want to just make it really clear
that all of the work that has been
described here
was carried out invasively as a part of
neurosurgical procedures in people
suffering from a seizure disorder called
epilepsy
and it's really been only through
the volunteer participation
of epilepsy patients who had
clinical indications for the electro
replacement
in the brain for these kind of
recordings
and why this is so important
so special and something i alluded to
during the talk is that for now
this is really the only way that we can
get this kind of resolution on the order
of million
millimeters in seconds simultaneously
um with this kind of uh resolution from
the human brain so
it's a very limited and constrained type
of
opportunity uh and a very special one at
that to really
be working with fellow human beings uh
who are volunteers in this
uh but um it is you know today
uh the only method to do that i'm i'm
hopeful
that in the future that we will have
better technology actually to
non-invasively
uh image and to get this kind of
resolution and
a lot of people are working on that now
i'm excited because that will have huge
implications even beyond
um the basic neuroscience wants uh
including for
clinical application but um we're not
there yet and so for the
for the time being this is a really
important modality that
is uh started to take off in more recent
years
good thank you that's um that's
interesting so
we have a lot of um of really great
questions on the platform
the first has to do with the cortical
representation
of pitch and the question is is it
emphasis or pitch
if i talk with a high pitch the whole
sentence will these pitch neurons go off
the entire time
yeah that's a really good question um
one of the key things that we wanted to
know with
ben's study that was focusing on the
larynx and the cortical control of the
larynx was
uh whether or not the time um
time locked activity that we're seeing
in the larynx cortex
was from uh
a linguistic kind of representation a
linguistic representation of when you
want to stress
something and and create that intonation
versus a more low-level representation
of the pitch
and uh what ben found was that it's the
latter
so he used some non-speech vocal
uh production controls where people were
actually
more or less singing sort of like a del
rey knee kind of
pattern to change pitch and he found
that in fact that this area was
um also responding to pitch changes in
the singing so
um the idea here is that it's not just
the pitch
in in in speech but in fact in in
non-speech vocalisations as well
you know and things that go beyond um
just linguistic operations
right next question is
what would you speculate would be the
difference in the brains of deaf people
that's a really interesting question um
so the question is
about in the setting of someone who is
deaf
uh what would the activity look like um
in this
motor cortex of the brain something that
i've described primarily
as a part of the brain that is
controlling the muscles
in the vocal tract one thing that i i
did not really talk about but what what
we and others have
actually seen is that in fact when
people hear
sounds in particular speech sounds
you can activate these parts of the
motor
cortex and there are in fact auditory
responses that we see
in this part of the brain in fact
when we saw this we had to ask even a
more fundamental question
was that we were assuming that
everything that we were seeing in terms
of the physiology was related to muscle
movements but in fact
could have been as a result of auditory
feedback
from what people were hearing themselves
say so that's why we did
a variety of controls to prove uh for
example that when you stimulate
in the larynx motor cortex it evokes emg
movement
at the level of the vocal folds um
the question about you know what would
be different in in people who are deaf
well
um i think that clearly
um the the control of movements um
grossly the same but what would be very
different is how auditory feedback
is integrated into these motor command
signals
and so we do know behaviorally for sure
um and also we're getting some evidence
these days that
the auditory cortex is plays a huge role
in regulating
and controlling uh the activity in the
speech motor cortex it's sort of like
guiding the vocal tract movements to the
right kind of our
articulatory targets and so
uh you know in people who are deaf it's
possible that
um that you can certainly learn to speak
fluently
uh without hearing uh but it's much
harder
compared uh to when you have hearing as
a feedback signal
so it might be um important how long
you've been deaf
um yeah i think things like that are
absolutely critical you know that
the uh the ability to understand and
comprehend language
uh as many of you know you know is very
influenced by early experience
and um the cochlear implant experiences
is
very telling about how important that
early exposure is to sound
sound and information about speech and
language
um there could be some similar things to
be said actually about our ability to
produce
speech as well whether or not there are
sensitive periods for the motor commands
that
allow us to speak fluently and how
critical it is actually to have both the
inputs and
outputs intact for the development of
normal language
um thank you um are there isometric
muscular contractions that are important
for speech
not captured by the movement monitoring
yeah so um that's a that's an
interesting
question so isometric muscle
contractions are basically
ones where uh you basically don't have
any movement
but the muscle is clearly contracted so
for example
if you're holding a book while you're
walking um
you're not moving your arms but you're
definitely contracting
those muscles in order to uh
double that posture and if i vocalize
a valve for example like ah
it's the same kind of thing where you
have to have an isometric muscle
contraction
uh that allows the position of the vocal
tract for that vowel
but it's actually not moving once i've
initiated one of our graduate students
um david conan actually did just that
project
where he had our subjects vocalize
steady state vowels
and what he found was that for the most
part what we were
seeing in the speech motor cortex wasn't
encoding
the movement but not the position of
the different parts of the vocal tract
so the lips the jaw
at the top um most of the neural
activity was time aligned to the onset
of the vowel and more or less
disappeared
during the steady state portion of it
and that was the first clear evidence
that we had that in fact
what we're seeing primarily is an
encoding of
movement and there's a different kind of
signal that encodes
how we hold that tone in that posture uh
it was a very critical experiment to
figure out whether or not it was the
position of the
the articulators versus the movement the
kinematic properties
of velocity and acceleration and what he
found was that it was a ladder
a lot of the neural activity that we see
there is encoding
the kinematic movement related
parameters
um to what extent can experiments in
songbirds or marmosets inform
the understanding of human speech
i really love that question because um
and this question is about how does how
do models from birdsong
and marmoset and um in general other
stones really inform the way
we think about human speech motor
control and i love this question because
i was trained primarily uh in labs that
were working on animal models and um
certainly the vast majority of the
analytical approaches and the
computational approaches that we've been
thinking about
speech both in the auditory cortex but
also in the motor cortex
is largely derivative of basic science
that is
done in animal models and i think that
this
is a really fascinating time to go back
and
do more comparative work to think about
what are the similarities
uh and what are the key differences
actually between
human and non-human vocal learners
and a lot of people are very interested
it's exciting to think that
um that in this coming decade that some
of those questions will be tractable
i think it's something very special and
unique that we have the ability to speak
where that comes from is still
fundamentally unknown
a lot of our work has really been
describing essentially some of the
properties but doesn't tell us really at
all why
that is the case or why it's so special
in human behavior
what are your thoughts for non-english
phone names
a minor remaining set of codes
great um you know what one thing that is
amazing about speech is that we think of
it
as this hallmark human behavior
something
unique and special about what humans do
but i think
something that is equally unique about
speech
is how diverse it is across different
languages
the fact that you know people can have
accents and across different
geographical
areas have completely different uh
speech patterns
is is is fascinating and
um there my response to that is really
two part one is that
there is to some degree a basic shared
code
meaning that the control of the vocal
tract and the
neural code that is used to break down
speech movements into individual
gestures is
highly overlapping across all languages
even though languages have different
forms
we still use the oral facial apparatus
and the muscles in ways that are is
relatively conserved but the way
that they are combined and sequenced is
very very different
and in fact one of the areas that we're
looking at right now
actually is how for example
in tone-based languages like manner
uh as an example where you have pitch
not
primarily for the use of intonation but
for
um what we call lexical expression
essentially when you change the pitch of
a word
in mandarin that changes it changes the
meaning of the word completely
um that's the use of pitch
for a completely different linguistic
purpose
and one of the our current projects is a
collaboration with
um some of our friends in shanghai who
um we've been working on a project to
understand how
the setting of lexical uh intonation or
the lexical um
tones actually is different than the
kind of processing that we do for stress
in english so it's a very fascinating
question we're just starting
to look into some of these questions
about whether or not um
there are differences and um and i think
in the next
couple of years something we'd like to
generalize beyond uh english and
mandarin to many other different
kind of languages that express speech in
different ways
well here's an interesting question what
do you think about the ability to
improve
performance over time uh with a longer
term device
right so um so the question is about
uh improving performance and uh
something that i said on
the recorded talk was that uh the
reconstructions that we were able to do
from speech uh we're far from perfect
i think they're really at the tip of the
iceberg in terms of
intelligibility really our first pass as
a proof of principle
there's no question that with more data
the accuracy
of this will improve and more data can
only be achieved by
um doing these experiments um or or
studies
in a more chronic setting you know a lot
of the stuff that we had done was really
on the orders of tens of minutes
and uh maybe 30 to 40 minutes worth of
data collection
so you can imagine uh how much better it
would get with
days potentially with devices that can
be permanently implanted in the future
for a neuroprosthetic application
how important was part one of the bmi
decoder which decodes into kinematic
trajectories and how poor
would performance be if you tried to
decode straight to spectrograms
great great question so this refers to
our project where we were doing
uh speech synthesis creating audio
waveforms
from the brain activity from speech
motor cortex
and um as many of you can imagine
there's
a lot of different ways to get from
brain activity to
an auditory waveform some people
would argue that if you just go directly
and have the neural network just
figure out everything that needs to go
in between that would be the best and
that's possibly true
especially if you have a lot of data
what we were trying to understand was
um what is the gain that you get from
building what we call by biomimetic
approach
essentially modeling what that part of
the brain
is essentially tuned to do which is to
produce stereotyped
trajectories articulatory trajectories
and what we found was
that if you explicitly model that
as an intermediate in the
in in the training algorithm if you
model that explicitly
the amount of data that is required is
dramatically lower
so we think obviously that with more
data you can do better and
with infinite amount of data you can
really really close that gap
but in many of the applications that
we're thinking about that's not possible
in many cases there's
no actual articulations that someone is
able to utter
so we're we really started thinking
about this as a way
of a biomimetic sort of modeling after
what the brain is naturally tuned to in
a way that we think is going to be
really clinically relevant so
it's definitely possible with different
approaches
but a lot of emphasis right now is how
to make it efficient
and optimal now we discussed this next
question a little bit before the session
and that do you have any sense from your
work about
individual to individual variation and
how speech
motor cortex is wired to produce sound
yeah um that's a really important
question
about you know how variable um
this speech motor control map this map
of the oral facial
gestures how different is it really
across individuals and
across our studies we found that it is
hugely variable
actually where the representations are
of you know these
lip movements and job movements
that being said while the absolute
position of all of these things
are highly variable across individuals
when you look
at the order of it it turns out that
that
is largely conserved so in general
we always see the same sequencing
in in but their absolute
locations is is highly variable so but
we always tend to see you know the
laryngeal representation at the highest
part
um followed by the labial the lip ones
followed by the tongue
jaw and then in some cases a secondary
laryngeal representation down at the
very bottom
and that that sequence is highly
conserved
so everyone's different but the general
pattern
is the same
do you um i know that i think others
have used penetrating electrodes have
you given any thought to
using that as a way to increase
resolution
yes um the kind of electrodes that we
are using are what we call
electrocorticography and these are just
platinum
small platinum discs about a one
millimeter in diameter
that are recording from thousands of
neurons so we're really looking
at the spatial average of thousands of
knots certainly not
single neurons and um i do think that
there's a lot to be learned
from um looking at single
single neurons in this area uh the
complicating thing
about this is that the real estate the
territory the cortical
territory that is involved with this
kind of processing is actually quite
huge
we're talking about three to four
centimeters along the motor
cortex and so the current technology
that we have right now really focuses
on you know the cortical um
real estate of about a centimeter so um
you know i think that there's a little
bit of a trade-off but there's no
question that there are a set of
questions that are really important to
answer with
uh penetrating electrodes that can
record from single single units from
this area
so we are just a little bit over time
but we've been given permission to run
just a few minutes late
there are so many good questions in the
question section so um
i know that you will enjoy looking at
those after the session but just to
wrap it up maybe with one more question
about ethics and that's
the the ethical dilemma that you
encounter in getting informed consent
in a group of patients who depend on you
for their care
can you comment on that dr trucia i'm
i'm really glad
that you brought that question up it was
a topic that i i wanted to address in
the original
uh had we done this um in in person
where there was more time allocated for
the talk but
um this was funded by a brain initiative
u1 project as part of a working group
called research in humans roh
i work with in this collaboration with
many other neurosurgical centers
neurological centers
scientists who are all really trying to
do
human neuroscience basic neuroscience
research in humans
a lot of this is taking place in
epilepsy patients and people with
movement disorders
and um this has been done actually for
decades
but i think that in recent years it's
really taken off
and so um one of the the great things
about the brand initiative
is that it's really provided resources
and provided
top-down leadership and prioritizing the
ethical
framework for doing this kind of work
when we started this 10-15 years ago
there really was no ethical framework or
or set of guidelines
and through this roh initiative we are
putting together a set of consensus
statements uh about what we think is the
right way to do this so that
we can really protect um the uh
patients that are are really
volunteering for this
kind of very basic uh kind of
neuroscience work
uh when we started with this um we knew
that
we were aware and sensitive to the
the issues and in particular some of the
ones that we've been thinking about are
informed consent uh for patients who are
undergoing these procedures in the
setting of
a clinical operation for example
and it's very important so we've created
many many
ways to protect um and safeguard
so that patients really fully understand
you know
what their rights are with participating
in research
constantly checking in with them about
their willingness to participate with it
um making sure to the best of our
ability
decoupling the treating physician my you
know my role in many cases
in trying to minimize that to primarily
having it separated
so that it's primarily carried out by
researchers who have different roles
are not directly related in their care
there's the list goes on
but the point is that that you know this
is a tremendous opportunity we have to
protect it
when it's done correctly it's it's
really a win-win a lot of our patients
participate in it um in
very high percentage and one what we've
what we've learned from this
is that largely their motivations are
the same truly it's just truly
altruistic
and it's it's actually higher i think in
our patient populations because
many people see the value of basic
research
even if it doesn't pertain to their own
cure of epilepsy for example
they all understand you know how
important it is for us to continue to
learn so
this is something that we're really
really invested
in protecting safeguarding to to keep it
as a win-win situation
great thank you and thank you for a
wonderful session thank you to all of
the
listeners who posed some great questions
and
um thanks a lot see you all later
thanks everyone